this landfill in buenos aires works in
an unexpected way
it turns methane leaking from the trash
into power
norte 3 is a 1 200 acre landfill site
the methane rising from the hill created
a plume so dense it could be seen from
space
but the site recently activated a new
power station
now it runs on methane gas piped under
the hill through tree trunk sized black
tubes
its five megawatts may be enough to run
only several thousand homes but they
represent a big victory in the fight
against climate change
[Music]
me
methane is one of the most powerful
greenhouse gases with more than 80 times
the warming impact of carbon dioxide in
the short term and landfill gas accounts
for one-fifth of methane releases
according to a un report
many countries like mexico france and
thailand are increasingly capturing it
to feed power production
in the u.s around 500 trash dumps
produce energy but there's a catch to
landfill gas power
one it often requires financial help
through a carbon credit scheme
and two only 40 of the methane at the
very most can be captured and piped to
plants
that's why environmentalists are
fighting for a future to generate way
less methane at landfills altogether
which basically means latin americans
will have to start composting
buenos aires is still taking baby steps
and separating its trash but the goal is
to have a two-pronged approach of
composting and capturing methane but the
ideal situation environmentalists say is
putting biogas plans at landfills out of
business entirely
[Music]